for many wishing for a white Christmas
but not like this a massive storm is
sweeping across the entire U.S 75
percent of the population will be living
with freezing temperatures by week's end
the storm extreme cold weather you can
see on the map the estimated areas where
the you know as low as 50 degrees where
it's at dark red below zero there's
dangerous and threatening this is really
a very serious weather alert here
it's a storm so big it has a name
Elliott the ice
the top concern the temperature on
Wednesday in Wyoming the temperature
dropped 17 degrees Celsius in just nine
minutes meteorologists are predicting
the storm will soon get another name
because of that a bomb Cyclone that is
when the atmospheric pressure drops at
least 24 millibars over 24 hours the
same pressure as a category 3 hurricane
and it's going to be widespread sweeping
down to the South as far as Texas and
other states that usually don't
experience extreme cold
heavy snowfall will also be an issue
with wind gusts expected in some places
as high as 80 kilometers an hour that
can create whiteout conditions and the
potential for people to become trapped
in their cars in temperatures that can
be fatal
and it's coming right in the middle of
the busiest travel season of the year
thousands of flights have been canceled
tired stressed hungry
just hopeless honestly the National
Weather Service is calling this storm a
once in a generation type event for much
of America a white Christmas but the
coldest one it's been in four decades
Patty culhane Al Jazeera